if you ever wondered what reflected
glory looks like this is it on behalf of
all those film historians film
preservationist and film collectors I
hear an intake of breath not so long ago
film collectors were endangered in this
town by a knock on the door from the FBI
I hope you have learnt that we were not
your enemies but my god you're your
predecessors did a terrible job of
preserving the silent era historian
David Pierce is about to reveal 73
percent has been destroyed now that's
like a publisher taking Tolstoy Dickens
scott Fitzgerald just pulping every copy
and you can't even see the manuscript
because they burnt that as well so it's
up to us to do our damnedest to find the
films that your predecessors destroyed
and bring them back into the Canon and
an awful lot is being done as you know
the recent find in New Zealand the
recent generosity from Russia but when I
think of some of the titles that have
gone it's it's really heartbreaking now
I was told when I started this business
that silent films are a complete waste
of time they were jerky flickery
ludicrously badly acted an appalling ly
photographed and I couldn't understand
it because I was already a film
collector and what I saw in beautiful
prints although sometimes abridged were
I was struck by the freshness the
vitality the innovation and the
exquisite photography Oh
and I really do regret the loss of black
and white it was a beautiful medium it
called upon me it called upon you to do
some work like silent film itself you
have to supply the voices and sound
effects and with black and white used to
play everything that the film suggested
and therefore you become part of the
creative process and it means that much
more now film is a collaborative medium
and I took it to its extremes I think
I've worked on practically everything
with a partner my wife of course for 41
years and she she is wearing tonight
jewelry given her by Alice teri matched
that then they're my partners and Romano
12 years David Gil 23 years last he died
in 97 and I better not leave out my
current producer Patrick Stanberry and
Christopher bird the most recent Co
director I've had a very fortunate life
as you can guess and to give you an
example I was very impressed by the
feature comedies of Harold Lloyd
he seemed if I wanted to convert someone
to silent films I just ran them a Lloyd
picture that's all you had to do but you
could not get hold of them he kept such
close grasp that it was we were reduced
to two for a long time and I knew the
fellow who had those two but he wouldn't
even consider exchanging or selling them
well I wrote a fan letter to Harold
Lloyd and I was very disappointed that
he didn't answer
celebrities don't you know and I was
dozing one Sunday morning and
I imagined I had last gone to Hollywood
and I was being shown around the motion
picture home by DW Griffith himself and
he said over there is a room with a
great camera man over there lives a very
fine editor and at the end of the
corridor the telephone rang in my head I
started tracking forward as one does and
I dissolved through and my telephone was
ringing so I went out into the hall and
picked it up and a voice said Kevin
you'll never guess who this is it's
Harold Lloyd he invited me to the
Dorchester Hotel and then began a long
and extremely fruitful friendship I
loved him
he was the actually was so charming he
should have been the the original of
Dale Carnegie's how to win friends and
influence people and I became fascinated
by what these people did they were the
most extraordinary people I'd ever met
in my life and I finally got to America
met them on mass it was not just the
stars but the cameraman the art
directors and even the title writers I
remember one of them Monty Brice told me
this his first title writing job he was
actually taken off the golf course
somebody had fallen ill no none of the
title writers were getting anywhere near
a good joke and so he came in in his
rather loud knickerbockers and these two
flex newspaper men all looked at him and
said that's your title writing outfit
huh and he said he had no idea what he
had to produce was a title which
suggested that Al st. John had left for
the city had failed in everything he'd
done and was returning he said to me God
send me a flash I said how about this
boys
I'll left home to set the world on fire
but had to come back for more matches
now it is amazing what's turning up and
if you would only let relax your
copyright laws we're silent films are
concerned you would see an awful lot
more suddenly appear that has been one
of the worst chains on this whole affair
of ours to try and rescue the past of
the cinema and I'll just tell you one
terrible story which sums it all up and
I've got the film that I shouldn't admit
this because it's probably copyright but
I have the film in which this appears
jr. Laemmle was in charge of the
Collegium series at Universal and
there's a sporting event a swimming
event which one college wins and they
build bonfires and they come home and
have a wild party we'll come back to the
college and have the wild party setting
the bonfires alight but it doesn't them
they don't burn strongly enough and
junior Lim Lisa's pile on the silent
negatives will never need them again and
on that note that cautionary tale they
burnt beautifully I'll leave you thank
you
you